both Carla Buda is never happier than
when he can take to the air he's the
director of an aircraft manufacturing
company and today he's flying a new era
light 120 for the first time an ultra
lightweight aircraft he said an airfield
in the German state of
mecklenburg-vorpommern that's having an
open house today
his wife Tilda is following everything
from the ground the colors look great
she says equipped with a small engine
and fuel tank the aircraft trundles
along at 90 km/h it can fly for up to
two hours at a time the great thing is
you're at the mercy of the elements and
on the basis of what you've learned you
then have to control the aircraft to
ensure you end up safely on the ground
it's a challenge but it's fun there's
always a bit of adrenaline involved it's
a great feeling to screw his green bird
as it's called is one of a number of
aircraft on display here but it's
attracting by far the most attention
it's an uncomplicated design and anyone
with a pilot's license for lightweight
recreational aircraft is allowed to fly
it I find it fascinating that they can
all get airborne with no problem at all
whether it's the big heavy airplanes or
lightweight aircraft like this one it's
cool to glide through the air and then
look down and see all the earth below
and everything looks so beautiful when I
get into a plane I can just switch off
and look down at the world you get a
whole different perspective and a sense
of freedom engineer Otto Lilienthal
wrote aviation history 125 years ago in
1891 when he became the first person to
fly 20 meters through the air in a self
built glider many more flights followed
lilienthal's home in unclaimed and
mecklenburg-vorpommern has dedicated a
museum to the german aviation pioneer
and chose reproductions of his flying
machines he constructed the 18 different
gliders from materials such as Willow
rod bamboo linen and wire he was
inspired by the way birds fly stalks in
particular Lily in town made his first
attempts at flying at age 43 just five
years later he died from injuries
sustained when his glider crash-landed
cracked the secret of the wings from
today's perspective when you look at
what modern planes still owe to Lily
until then it's the physics of the wings
we still describe the wings of an Airbus
using the same terms Lily and tile came
up with 130 years ago back to Vulcan
labuda his company fear vecas located
just 40 kilometers as the crow flies
from Ottawa Lillian tells birthplace the
early light 120 is assembled here by
hand built on a frame composed of
aviation grade aluminium the plane's
wings are covered with high-tech
polyester fiber from the United States
fie avec has created 12 different
designs okay it's a great feeling you
open a box take out the individual parts
and work with them you must be sure that
what you're doing is right and in the
end you sit in the thing and flies
seeing the world from a bird's eye view
is something that also fascinates as why
tilda though she doesn't have a pilot's
license herself she's long been
entranced by the magic of flying we have
great respect for Otto Lilienthal and
his pioneering vision of learning how to
fly we're carrying that on a little with
our style of flying people can still be
hungry for adventure without being
reckless investors why does all of our
Kaiser survive the errand I turn Otto
Lilienthal models have in common that
they offer pilots that thrill of
adventure but these days planes are more
than a hobby for thrill seekers they
have of course become an essential mode
of transport as well